大家好,下面我给大家来介绍一下在分销商模式下,怎样进行实时同步数据,首先点击左边菜单的最后一个实时同步数据,在这个页面可以看到有实时同步的规则设定,以及查看同步的记录,我们先来看一下同步的规则,在这里的话可以看到这里有一条同步规则。
我们下面来添加一条同步的关联规则,点左边的查询,点右边的查询,左边是上级的分销商店铺,右边是您的店铺。
在这里的话您可以选自动关联商品,那系统的话会根据两个店铺商品的编码或者标题自动进行关联,自动匹配。
如果他们没有一致的编码或者标题也不一样,您可以进行手动关联商品,我们来试一下。
在关联配置这个页面上,左边是您的设计分销商,右边是您的店铺。
在这个页面上您看到,您可以选择把它拖载过来,这样它就匹配上了。
当然也可以选择第二种方式,您在这个小块里输入左边的续号,比如说它现在的续号是1。
如果有很多个STU,它后面下面会有很多的,比如234这样很多。
下面我们来输个1,然后点击下方便,它自动的就会过来了。
另外还有第三种方式就是您点击这个自动匹配,它也可以过来。
自动匹配的话,只有当它这个名字或者编码,它是一致的情况下它才能自动匹配。
如果都不一样,它也匹配不上。
好了,当这个已经匹配上之后的话,您点击确定关联对应就算设置好了。
我们来推出,点一下匹效,来这里查询一下,刷新看一下。
这一条就是我们刚刚创建的关联对应关系,可以点击查看。
可以看到它已经在这里了,在这里随时可以修改,比如我不想关联了。
把它再拖过来,点击确定就可以了。
它可以随时把它先进掉,随时可以再把它打开。
进掉之后它就不会再自动实施这个同步了。
再把它打开,它就可以再同步了。
同样的话,这里有一些批量修改的按钮,比如批量的伤出。
批量伤出,点一下它就会把这些关联都删掉,也可以批量修改。
比如说现在实时同步的数据已经不太一样了,我现在只要把它批量修改为只同步库车,那么点一下确定。
可以看到已经批量全部修改为只同步库车。
当然这些启用和精英网也是可以批量修改的。
那比如说我在这里查询出来的,现在就有两个,假如说你有好几个页,好几页的话可能就几百个。
那您可以选择第二个直接,比如说把它选这个。
您现在我只需要改状态,把它改成金用,那我点确定。
好了,就全部批量金用,这样当您在需要的时候再把它全部给打开,这些都是可以的。
那这里的这个关联对应好了,创建好了之后的话,那系统就会在后台自动的为您进行这个数据的同步。
注意这里是单向同步,也就是说在分销商模式下,您只能从您的上级分销商把数据同步过来。
而不能把您这边的数据的变动给同步给您的上级分销商,这是不能同步给上级的,只能从上级往下级分销商同步。
然后您在这边点这个按钮,可以查看到一些同步的记录。
如果这里有同步的这个发声的话,这里会有一些同步的记录,在这里您都可以随时搜索查看。
特别要提一点的话,这里的关联的关系存在之后的话,当您在进行手动同步的时候,如果您在这里创建规则,在这个地方您就可以选择实时同步的关联。
就可以利用刚才我们的礼,已经有的这些实时同步的关联来进行打定,进行手动同步。
好了,给大家介绍实时同步就到这里。谢谢。